ce qu'on a essayé de souligner dans ce
bouquin c'est que aujourd'hui on était
dans une période très étrange dans
laquelle finalement on a tout un tas de
signaux pour ceux qui veulent se donner
la peine de bien les regarder et qui
montre qu on a une tempête qui s'annonce
sauf que pour le moment la tempête est
absolument pas là et que le baromètre
est encore à peu près je dis bien à peu
près au beau fixe parce que ceux qui
font partie des cent mille chômeurs
supplémentaires par mois
si le regarde on y trouve en effet une
boule de définition du beau fixe ce qui
est très ennuyeux dans cette histoire
c'est que en fait on ne se rend pas
compte du fait que notre économie a été
bâtie sur un château de sable et que ce
château de sable va avoir ses fondements
sap et que ça nous plaise ou que ça vous
plaise pas et que si on ne prend pas la
peine de d'essayer de réorienter
l'économie avec avec un préavis
suffisant
et bien cette affaire là va se faire de
manière spontanée
objectivement la les activités des
hommes vont se voir contraintes de
manière spontanée est extrêmement
violente et quand on a des
déstabilisations économique extrêmement
violente l'histoire nous montre que ça
débouche très facilement sur de
l'oppression politique c'est à dire la
dictature ou sur des guerres ou sur une
savante combinaison de tout un tas de
trucs que je ne souhaite à personne
alors la crise actuelle elle est très
facile à relier pour moi aux problèmes
d'énergie parce que l'énergie est
quelque chose qui est indispensable à
n'importe quelle transformation du monde
donc quand vous avez le prix du pétrole
qui est multiplié par 10 en l'espace de
quelques années vous freiner la
possibilité de transformer le monde de
chauffer de déplacés de transformer de
transporter et caetera et donc vous avez
l'économie qui ralentit depuis 1970 vous
n'avez pas eu une hausse significative
du prix du pétrole a commencé par les
chocs pétroliers de 74 et 79 où tout le
monde se souvient qu'ils ne se soient
pas terminés par un ralentissement très
fort voire une récession sur un certain
nombre de zones économiques un peu large
et là il est en train de se produire
exactement la même chose
les âneries des banques qui ont fait
tout ce qu'elle pouvait pour s'abstraire
de leurs ratios de solvabilité n'a pas
créé la crise
ça l'a amplifiée est retardé
il faut prendre le problème dans leur
camp
et de ce qui ne va pas vers ce qu'il a
il ya eu un premier un premier élément
important qui je souhaite qu'on reste en
démocratie un deuxième élément important
c'est que depuis monsieur tocqueville on
considère que la démocratie est
indissociable d'une forme d'économie de
marché
on peut la réguler un peu plus un peu
moins on peut sortir un certain nombre
de domaines du marché par exemple la
justice n'est pas dedans
la construction des routes peut ne pas y
être etc mais globalement mon producteur
du carottes bail est ce plutôt une bonne
chose
à partir du moment où vous êtes dans une
économie de marché pour une large partie
de l'activité des hommes il ya un truc
qui est absolument constance et que si
vous ne donnez pas appris à un problème
le problème n'est pas traité comme des
grandes règles d'économie de marché
c'est qu'ils voulaient les gens
s'occupent d'un problème pour lui donner
un prix à partir du moment où vous
considérer qu'on va avoir des problèmes
avec le système énergétique que nous
avons actuellement qui est basé sur un
truc qu'on considère comme un fusil
alors qu'il n'est pas et qu'on considère
comme sans effet alors qu'il n'est pas
il faut donner un prix à la finitude des
ressources il faut donner un prix au
fait que le changement climatique doit
avoir des conséquences dramatiques pas
tout de suite plus tard et à ce moment
il faut mettre en oeuvre ce qu'on
appelle une taxe carbone c'est à dire
donner un prix croissants au problème
alors ça va déplacer toutes les
activités partout et tout le temps et ça
va avoir un effet qui va être très
désagréable qui va être la contraction
du pouvoir d'achat mais qu'on va avoir
de toute façon parce que beaucoup de
gens pensent que le prix des produits ne
dépend que notre bonne volonté
c'est faux si demain matin passé le pic
de production du pétrole
il y en a de moins en moins et que en
plus celui qui reste est de moins en
moins disponibles pour les européens est
de plus en plus pour les chinois les
indiens les américains et les brésiliens
et bien que ça vous plaise observons
presse pas vous en aurez moins pour
mettre dans une voiture
non avant
manière la souffrance ou l'arize au
régime
mais il n'y aura pas de repas gratuits
donc il faut qu'on soit bien conscient
de cette affaire-là la taxe carbone est
un moyen de déplacer le système en
douceur en laissant encore énormément de
place à l'espoir aux opportunités au
projet parce que toute contrainte fait
toujours naître des projets d espoir et
d opportunités
il ya éveil a que comme ça qu'on y
arrive
une bonne partie des gens dans notre
pays sont parfaitement schizophrène et
contradictoires considère qu'il y avait
un problème grave qu'il faudrait qu'on
règle sans que cela de leur canapé de
faye quoi que ce soit et que les autres
noms qu'elle gérait à leur place
malheureusement c'est pas vrai et ça ça
pose un problème majeur en démocratie
c'est que contraindre les lecteurs en
démocratie est un truc que le pouvoir
politique ne s'est pas bien faire une
application pratique de cette histoire
c'est que les lecteurs n comptable sur
l'industriel et est moins qu'on lui tape
dessus à lui donc les lecteurs par
exemple n qu'on mette des normes sur la
manière de produire et aime beaucoup
moins qu'on mette des taxes à la
consommation de ce qui pose problème
toujours on continue à prendre un coup
de zoom de plus en plus important ça
veut donc dire que dès que vous parlez
de taxes qui est décidé à dissuader les
gens de faire quelque chose c'est le cas
pour le tabac c'est le cas pour l'alcool
et c'est le cas pour les énergies
fossiles des lecteurs des fois ça sauf
si vous lui servez une explication de
texte qui est extrêmement longue et pas
facile à faire parce que le pouvoir
politique s'exprime à travers des médias
qui réduisent tout à une ou deux minutes
et servir des explications longues et
détaillées et pédagogique dans ce genre
de leucate avec ce genre de créneau est
un truc qui n'est pas facile
il avait compris c'était un truc est
électoralement payant de parler
d'environnement et puis il faut pas
oublier que le grenelle a été montée et
concocté par un homme qui a disparu du
paysage actuellement s'appelle alain
juppé et que c'était un processus qui
avait été conçu par elle pour lui
beaucoup plus le parcours borloo donc en
fait borloo dans cette histoire il
hérite d'un truc qui avait déjà été mis
sur les rails
on peut le regarder comme un ver
ou un verre à moitié plein comme
d'habitude la partie verre à moitié
plein c'est qu'on a fait on a on a
initié un dialogue entre des gens qui se
parlent est moins avant c'est que ça
débouche et à l'occasion du grenelle sur
des réformes de structures qui sont pas
des réformes mineurs par exemple la
fusion de certains corps dans
l'administration
le voilà donc on va dire qu'il ya quand
même eu quelques effets intéressants
ça a permis dans un certain nombre de
milieux économiques aux gens qui se
préoccupent d'environnement de devenir
des interlocuteurs légitimes
donc il ya un certain nombre
d'entreprises par exemple où les gens
n'hésitent plus à dire ouvertement que
c'est des sujets importants
ça c'est une des conséquences du
grenelle avant ces gens là ils étaient
un peu plus cacher un peu plus honteux
il s'exprimait un peu moins violemment
et c'est le verre à moitié vide c'est
que on a besoin de monter sur l'everest
et que là on a fait le huitième du quart
des chiens jusqu'au camp de base qu'on
est pressé par le temps et que tout ça
traîne considérablement et la raison de
fond pour laquelle ça traîne c'est que
la majeure partie des concepteurs
politique du grenelle continue à penser
que tout ça mais juste une
c'est juste une affaire des aménagements
à la marge dans un monde qu'il reste un
fini donc ils ont absolument pas compris
la réalité de la contrainte
on va de tout
monde qui s'annonce des places est de
moins en moins le 19e et 20e siècles ont
été caractérisés par un accès à une
énergie de plus en plus abondante et de
moins en moins chers qui permet d'aller
de plus en plus loin de plus en plus
vite et pour de moins en moins cher et
ça ça va probablement s'inverser
ça a commencé peut-être et sinon ça va
s'inverser dans cinq ans dans dix ans
dans 15 ans donc les gens qui ont 20 ans
aujourd'hui
terminons leur existence dans un monde
dans lequel on prendra plus l'avion
comme on respire pour des raisons
physiques
donc c'est voilà donc il faut faire avec
c'est une survie très bien c'est juste
une affaire veut pas se faire des
illusions
pouvait très bien passé l'hiver dans une
pièce à vis de l vous en mourrez pas
toute la question est de savoir ce qu'on
appelle un luxe est en fait vous vous
rendez compte que la barrière se
déplacent constamment au fil de l'eau
fil des années et des décennies
aujourd'hui prendre l'avion les gens
considèrent que c'est pas un luxe
il ya un siècle ça n'existait pas il ya
50 ans il y avait marcel cerdan qui
prenaient l'avion et général de gaulle
voilà les autres ils prenaient pas
l'avion donc ce qu'il ya 50 ans était un
hyper luxe aujourd'hui c'est presque un
produit de consommation courante pour
quelques dizaines d'euros ou prenez
l'avion si ça vous amuse
si vous voulez faire construire une
maison c'est très simple vous appelez un
entrepreneur général ait voulu déjouer
une maison le tipi s'occupe de tout il
trouve le type qui pose les fenêtres et
trouve le type qui pose des radiateurs
et robotique qui va faire les fondations
et y trouve tout si aujourd'hui vous
voulez avoir voulu faire rénover
thermiquement un logement et que
l'entrepreneur général en innovation
n'existe pas donc vous passer six mois
et qu'ils aient trouvé le plombier qui
va bien le ballon qui va bien le
menuisier qui va bien et sait si la
croix et la bannière et le parcours du
combattant
donc dans un plan industriel vous avez
le besoin de former 50 ou 100 mille
artisans du bâtiment pour qu'ils sachent
faire ce genre de truc est dans un plan
industriel un peu coercitif vous pouvez
même leur dire je vous préviens si vous
ne savez pas faire ce genre de trucs
vous oubliez la tva à 5 et demi sur vos
travaux je voulais repasser à 19,6 je
pense que ça va on va tirer un certain
nombre
tu as fait un siècle et demi qu'on fait
du progrès
anti fiq et techniques en un siècle et
demi la consommation d'énergie mondiale
a été multipliée par cent cinquante la
consommation d'énergie par individu a
été multiplié par plus de dix la
concentration de co2 dans l'atmosphère a
augmenté de 100 parties par million les
surfaces de forêts mondiales ont
significativement diminué le stock de
poissons dans l'atlantique nord a été
divisée par plus de dix donc le progrès
scientifique
il crée autant de problèmes qu'il n'en
résout et si j'essaye d'être un tout
petit peu plus précis
la technologie n'est pas auto porteuse
de solutions la technologie s'investit
là où le système socio-économique lui
dit d'aller si le système
socio-économique 10 qui compte c'est la
croissance
la technologie est mise au service de la
si ce que le système socio-économique
dit c'est la technologie doit être mise
au service de la préservation du capital
naturel qui nous permettra d'avoir des
sociétés stables et heureuse demain
parce que essayer de faire une société
stable et heureux sur la lune ça marche
très bien à ce moment le progrès
scientifique ira se mettre là dedans
donc en fait ce qui conditionne
l'orientation du progrès scientifique et
technologique
c'est les orientations économiques et
sociales dont nous nous dotons ce qui
fait que la technologie est une source
de progrès ou une source d'emmerdements
c'est essentiellement ce que la loi dira
ce que le règlement dire à ce que
l'économie dira au sens de jeu pénalise
ceux ci et je favorise cela à travers un
truc qui s'appelle la fiscalité
je suis pas du tout
l'énergie de demain parce que si le
pétrole serait abaissée et le gaz se met
à baisser en production la consommation
ne manquera pas il n'existe pas de monde
où vous ayez une production de pétrole
qui baisse et une consommation de
pétrole qui augmente donc un milliard
d'habitants soit pas grand chose par
habitant ça peut faire beaucoup mais il
faut pas oublier que c'est pas grand
chose par habitant aujourd'hui la
consommation d'énergie d'un indien c'est
un dixième de la consommation d'énergie
d'un français est ce que les indiens
sont des affres autres champs ou est-ce
que c'est nous les infos cochon moi
j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire que si
par exemple vous prenez l'europe la
consommation d'énergie de l'europe
n'auront peut-être pas 450 millions
d'habitants elle est à peu près cinq
fois plus élevé que la consommation
d'énergie de la reine